there was a there's a line in the
documentary that blew my mind so hard
uh when your parents are fighting and
you're growing up around that and your
father says
uh we fight because we love each other
this is what people who are in love do
i was so young when i heard it and it
and it stuck with me and it clearly
affected my mother and i've spoken to my
father about this since and
you know in that moment maybe he was
thinking he was saying the right thing
to try to calm down a young child but
you know it's these it's it's these
moments and these things that uh you
know for me the hardest part
i always tell people as a parent is is
the things you pass on to your children
that you don't mean to
and and um and it's unavoidable it's
it's just there's no perfect parent
there's no perfect survivor there's no
perfect person you know we all make
mistakes and and that's why i was very
you know proud of my parents for putting
themselves out there like this and you
know i know my parents grew up in a time
where therapy was seen as something to
be ashamed of and it meant you were
crazy and nobody talked about these
feelings there was a sort of a different
approach to parenting
um which is just like do as i say not as
i do you know like don't speak until
you're spoken to you know that that kind
of reality
exactly and that's what is so incredible
about the journey that you do open up
with around this incredible subject of
what you went through by including your
family and how you've grown up and
learned together as a unit now then your
mom and dad split up
you guys go to los angeles your dad and
your brothers stay in north carolina
and
you are 19 when you meet this person who
is so captivating
so alluring
this man is giving you cameras
you know you think you're making art yes
you're in a place where you can like you
know do some substances feel free take
every you know feel that abandonment
that wildness was that a part of like
the entry point
of course yeah you lure people in with
this promise of this is a better way
this is freedom this is you can be who
you really are
um we're going to have fun we're going
to do this a different way and i think
that's what drew me to brian because i
thought wow look what he's doing
for young people and the way you know
he's like challenging you know the
status quo and social norms and so
that's what
uh i you know i looked at him as a
mentor you know
sexy and it's hot he's in front of all
these crowds you buy in you drink the
kool-aid you drink the kool-aid and the
the the analogy uh
we often use is you know it's the
lobster slowly boiling in the pot you
don't just stick it straight into the
boiling water stick it in you know cold
water and you're just slowly turning the
heat up until suddenly you're like
i'm sorry are you cooking me alive
and and that is sort of
the analogy for
gaslighting and grooming and and and
brainwashing
and that you know you're you're lured
into this false sense of security at
first and this is why
abusive relationships can be so
complicated because so much of the abuse
is disguised as love and that this is
for your own good or you don't know what
you're talking about somebody really
takes control and is somebody that felt
so inferior to everybody my whole life
and like
just conditioned not to trust myself and
to trust the adults in the room and then
i dated somebody that was 20 years older
than me he to me he's the adults in the
room and he probably knows better than
me and so they made me trust them uh you
know they were they were telling me
things that that happened to them and
then you feel like wow they've shared
something so intimate i'm going to share
something so intimate and then you start
giving up your secrets your
vulnerabilities
and it's the wolf in sheep's clothing
you know they're sitting there
you know saying yeah no absolutely but
really they're mining information and
they're going okay so that's what that's
what she's insecure about okay she's got
this this relationship that's broken
down in her life i can attack that and
then okay that's what she's afraid of so
i'll just like you know feed into that
and we don't think this way and so we
can't imagine that somebody else would
but people do when you are a kind
altruistic loving caring person you
don't believe that other people are out
to get you innocent that's why you can't
see it and you want the best out of
people
[Music]
you